si les nouvelles générations entendent
encore aujourd'hui parler de coluche
c'est également pour la création des
restos du coeur et le lancement de la
troupe des [ __ ] qui chaque année se
réunit pour récolter des fonds pour les
plus démunis mais dans les années 70 80
en france coluche était une véritable
star de l'humour un personnage très
populaire adulé par de nombreux français
avec son expression inimitable c'est
l'histoire d'un mec c
histoire ou son sketch occulte le
schmilblick
est ce que le schmilblick après 39 40
non monsieur dental m'étonne pas ce sont
tous des planqués la télévision coluche
a marqué l'histoire très populaire sur
scène il fera des apparitions sur grand
écran dans l'aisne où la cuisse et de
nombreuses comédies de l'époque
mais c'est en 1984 qu'il obtient le
césar du meilleur acteur pour son rôle
dramatique dans le film tchao pantin de
claude berri aujourd'hui encore citer en
référence le gagnant et coluche
charpente est à montrouge d'une famille
très populaire coluche se sont proches
des gens qui souffrent des exclus des
marginaux et de ceux qui n'ont pas la
chance comme lui de manger à leur faim
c'est cette raison et un goût prononcé
pour la provocation qui le pousse à se
présenter aux élections présidentielles
de 1981 face à giscard et mitterrand
si cette annonce ressemble d'abord à une
blague et très vite les intentions de
vote qui le créditent à plus de 10%
inquiète la classe politique censuré par
les principaux médias
l'humoriste décide de jeter l'épongé
épuisé et affaibli par les différentes
stations dont il fait l'objet
à partir du moment où ça m'a plus fait
rire évidemment ça se gâte un peu
puisque six mois ça me fait pas rire
comment je vais le faire pour faire rire
les autres ces quatre ans plus tard
qu'il trouvera un moyen de faire
concrètement avancer les choses enfants
dans les restos du coeur il ya
officiellement 600 mille personnes
seront pas à boucler en france quoi tous
les jours un an seulement après avoir
lancé les restos du coeur coluche perd
la vie dans un accident de moto à l'âge
de 41 ans une disparition prématurée qui
marquera durablement les français romain
goupil être avec vous êtes réalisateur
ancien directeur de la campagne
présidentielle de coluche alors coluche
comment il a l'idée de se présenter je
crois que c'était s'était fait virer
dérens et à la radio ça c'est à dire
qu'il y avait eu une première à
licenciement sur la plainte des anciens
combattants qui disait sur europe 1
qu'il avait pu sa place à l'antenne
l'accord rmc trouve malin de faire la
nique à europe 1 et l'invite pour animer
une émission et il cherchait un
assistant parce que lanvin commencé lui
à travailler dans le cinéma comme acteur
et ils vont me proposer
l'imprésario va me proposer en disant hé
est ce que tu veux être l'assistant et
préparer ses émissions avec michel je
dis jamais fait ça ouais mais tu es
assistant oui mais tu bosses avait
écarté les rater
et donc dis moi si t'es ok alors oui il
parait qu'il paraît que l'idée d'être
président alors au début c'était une
connerie et à préparer que pas que c'est
johnny hallyday notamment qu'il a
chauffé un peu eddy mitchell sais c'est
pas du tout une connerie c'est à dire
qu'on se fait virer de rmc parce qu'on
n'arrête pas de faire des blagues sur
les dames en est sûre giscard et sur les
diamants et surgit ce cas on arrête pas
de casse à l'époque oui les diamants de
bokassa donc on arrête pas déconner là
dessus au bout de trois jours ils
décident de nous virer
ils attendent quand même la fin de la
semaine on peut s'en servir ça va être
un souk terrible et qu'on rende un
chambre d'hôtel et qui nous annonce à
jeudi à michel la seule solution ça fait
quand même deux fois compte empêche de
parler la seule solution c'est que tu te
présentes
les élections présidentielles et donc à
partir de là on a commencé ensemble sur
la base de l'indemnité que j'avais qui
était énorme
j'étais extrêmement bien payé pour être
l'assistant de michel et là j'avais
devant moi trois mois ou quatre mois et
je lui dis c'est à ta disposition et en
avant vers la lèvre à la cadence et donc
c'était sérieux ah c'était carrément
sérieux oui il ya eu un dîner des dîners
avec johnny hallyday ou audi ou dit
michel oui il lui disait il faut qu'ils
aillent non mais il y avait tous les
dîners tous les soirs la rue gazan été
transformé en bureau politique comme on
avait quand on avait quitté sa maison
avec renault alors là qu'avait son rond
de serviette qui était tout le temps là
il y avait lanvin il y avait veillé à
jeanjean enfin toupatou toute la clique
était là et après il y avait les invités
ce qui passait pour prendre un pot plus
tard alors c'était quand c'est pas
isabelle huppert c'est eddy mitchell
quand c'est pas johnny s'est laissé tout
le monde y croyait tout le monde ces dix
ont connu c'est pas qu'ils croyaient
c'est qu'ils disaient allons-y ensemble
ça fait 23 ans que c'était les mêmes qui
étaient au pouvoir 23 ans de la droite
donc à partir d' à partir du moment où
il y avait 23 ans de gouvernement ou là
tout le monde se ressemblaient séquence
est pas là c'était l'autre c'était
l'autre c'était le dial tu va amener
quelque chose de nouveau
là dessus le projet au démarrage ce
n'est pas du tout ça c'était dire
inscrivez vous sur les listes
électorales ça vous appartient
l'élection c'est à vous dont vous
inscrivez et non nous on peut faire
changer les choses avec vous alors nous
comme candidat mais vous en votant il
paraît qu'il ait pas de programme précis
vous étiez parti en plein délire vous
avez décidé sur un coup de tête du
slogan bleu-blanc merde est votre
programme de base avait aucun sens lui
dit vous voulez simplement faire embêter
tout le monde voilà et vous aviez il
faut 500 signatures pour se présenter à
la présidentielle tout le monde croyait
que vous aviez les 500 signatures mais
ce que vous les aviez c'est à dire que
là c'est là devient mot surnom
d'éminences noir j'ai toujours une
petite mallette noire est dedans je
tiens le compte des signatures de maires
à chaque discussion avec chaque
journaliste
il faut que je me souvienne en marquant
sur ma main ce que j'ai racontée comme
baratin la fois suivante est obligé de
montrer ma main à michel puisque on
s'embrouille si on remettait nos
interviews y en a un moment on est à 50
un moment à 160 à me ment à dix s'est
inscrite en fait la vraie vraie vérité
puisque j'avais cette mallette c'est que
nous on avait une signature ah oui on a
jamais eu qu'une signature à lyon n'a
menti tout le temps pour dire on
approche on va être candidat
robin et la signature à la dernière
seconde
le maire a que j'ai filmé dans le petit
film l'a retiré de sa mère s'est retiré
il paraît que vous attendiez vous
attendiez pas du tout à ce qu'il ait 16%
d'estimation de vote et vous dit qu'à ce
moment là coluche est rentré dans le
truc il s'est pris au sérieux et là vous
allez décider de qui là il va se passer
un truc c'était laid ce qu'ils rendent
tout de suite dans l' aventure serra qui
rient ils disent nous si jamais les
présidents ou devient le journal
officiel et ses claques on sort la fiche
le candidat bleus blanc merde
assis sur les chiottes et c'est
d'accorder le truc qui va être dans
toutes les mairies et à partir du moment
où ils sont journal officiel
on va inventer tous les jours une petite
affichette toutes les semaines petites
affichettes à coller ça valait la peine
le coluche d'appel à candidatures
j'appelle tous les feignants les drogués
les ex-communistes les [ __ ] le sait ça
normal il s'est pris au jeu au moment où
on peut pas lui en vouloir
non là là on déconne avec ses dîners
avec eddy mitchell et tout est à partir
du moment où tombent et sont à 16% dans
l'observateur 10% dans le matin de paris
qui était un journal de l'époque
là tout d'un coup il dit mais j'ai
peut-être un rôle à jouer parce qu'une
élection en france de tous temps ça joue
à deux points et là on était crédité de
16 c'est donc tout d'un coup il s'est
dit mais peut-être ce que je dis est
intéressant alors que notre programme
c'était plus d'argent plus de travail
plus de mariages plus de nous branles
branlée en plus rien [ __ ] avec lolo
qui était la fille qui était payée rue
gazan à rouler des joints toute la nuit
oui ça par le groupe il vous allez nous
parler des pressions politiques s'il a
reçu ou pas dans un instant coluche vous
saurez tout la vérité
et puis on exclusivité vous allez nous
lire la lettre que connu ce que coluche
avait écrite quand il a dit j'arrête
vous l'avez sur vous c'est vraiment un
document exclusif à lire dans un instant
n'en touche pas à mon poste en direct
vous nous parler de la candidature de
coluche romain goupil
merci d'être là vous avez été on y voit
là son directeur de campagne lorsqu'il a
décidé de se présenter aux élections
et est ce que coluche vous nous en
parler il ya un instant est ce qu'il a
subi des pressions parce qu'on a
entendues partout qu'il a subi des
pressions d'autres politiques la même
gens les gens qui crient au complot sur
la mort de paul hus qu'il aurait reçu
des menaces des menaces
est ce que c'est vrai tout ça ou pas non
elle n'y a aucun moment il ya deux
menaces pour nous empêcher d'être
président puisque on a une signature et
que les flics savent pertinemment c'est
leur boulot ou alors c'était plus les
flics les plus cons que j'aie jamais
connue ils sont pas capables de savoir
que au niveau des mers et au niveau des
conseils généraux personne n'a signé
donc on ne peut pas se présenter à leur
résidence
à partir du moment où on fait l'erreur
une erreur manifeste qui est celle de
michel de prendre tout ça trop au
sérieux
bien sûr que quand la campagne va
réellement commencer avec les candidats
classiques
il est mis à l'écart par les
journalistes c'est à dire quand on bat
qu'une l'interviewer parce que on
considère que c'est un clown parce que
il vend son spectacle du gymnase jeu et
donc lui va super mal le vivre
il va il va confondre le personnage
public
le personnage politique qui s'est pris
au sérieux et du coup il va inventer
avec son entourage l'imprésario va
inventer ce complot mais cela dit les
flics sont vraiment très con parce que
eux aussi vont inventer les limites la
république et vont lui envoyer des
lettres de menace avec un petit cercueil
une petite balle
alors maintenant c'est la section 14 des
rêves d'hergé maintenant il s'en vanter
le revendique sa section direction des
rg qui a envoyé cette lettre en disant
on va influencer la campagne influencer
la campagne
c'est n'importe quoi les maires refusé
eh ben les maires refusé parce que il
savait que c'était un clown et qu'il
n'avait aucune compétence sur son
programme pour diriger la france
peut-être pour être un élu municipal de
et encore j'en sais rien c'était un
déconneur
c'était l'équipe le bureau politique
c'était gb reiser c'était cabu c'était
boloni donc c'était hara kiri avec ça va
la feria du conseil des ministres si tu
peux aller très loin on a été au plus
loin alors on pourrait voir un extrait
c'est lorsque coluche explique les
raisons qui l'ont poussé à se présenter
à l'élection présidentielle
et c'est vrai qu'on voit qu'il a un
discours bien rodé mine de rien coluche
rien je ne demande pas été lu lé 20
millions cinq cent mille chômeurs comme
les [ __ ] comme les les lèvres comme
tous les parasites les fondeurs de
patins à roulettes les appelés du
contingent et tout ça sont des gens qui
pour l'instant sont rachetées par la
société qui ne valent rien vis à vis des
hommes politiques même de gauche ma
candidature
dumora et comment j'ai voté pour rien
pendant longtemps les ondes en tout cas
on fait comment ils ont voté pour rien
aujourd'hui on veut le rondin voter pour
quelqu'un qui politiquement n'est rien
ils nous prennent pour des imbéciles
voix contre 1 appelle la lie quand il
est à quel moment là il commence et on
est au tout début les bureaux des codes
et on veut simplement que tout le monde
se sente concerné d'où l'appel c'est un
fait incroyable affiche qu'est le début
j'appelle tous les drogués tous les
zonards tous les [ __ ] tous les ex
communistes à soutenir ces candidatures
pour celle là ça ressemble pour leur
[ __ ] au cul prayssas notre programme
et c'est la première affiche sortie par
hara kiri
mais pour il se passe un truc absolument
extraordinaire c'est que cette première
conférence de presse on l'a fait au
théâtre du gymnase
il ya absolument tout la jambe le
répertoire de l'imprésario et il ya tous
notre répertoire des journalistes
politiques qui va nous avons une fois
six mois avant l'élection ou un
spectacle complètement déments et lui
peut s'exprimer devant tout le monde et
déconner devant tout le monde
donc il va trouver des bons mots des
blagues dès lors c'est son boulot c'est
devenu aujourd'hui avec un document
extrêmement fort c'est la lettre que
vous envoyez coluche lorsqu'il a décidé
d'arrêter ben mahmoud elle voulait
rajouter quelque chose alors je dis
qu'il faut il faut maintenant le
contexte on était sous la france giscard
qui était une france très bourgeoise et
conservatrice donc l'audace tout ce
qu'ils disaient c'était d'une audace
folle peut-être que michaud a pas
énormément exactement alors l'or mais
grâce à lui s'est passé il ya plein de
choses qui sont passés sur red gbt sur
les homos bien sûr que toutes les
insultes homophobes qui existait il a
participé par cette campagne et par ses
sketches sur leurs assises a surtout les
sketchs qu'on connaît il a changé la
france alors la lettre que coluche je
vous en voyez que vous avez décidé dans
un premier temps de ne pas publier
puisqu'il vous envoyer ce document
extrêmement fort et dans cette lettre
si vous pouvez nous lire le début on a
on a on a sélectionné les passages c'est
la première fois qu'on lit cette lettre
c'est vraiment un document exclusif
qu'est ce qui dit au début de cette aide
quand ils arrêtent connu c'est à dire
que on se fâche
à partir du moment où ça
la campagne commence à piétiner ils
restent sur place il est interdit
d'antenne pour d'autres raisons par les
raisons qu'il explique
et là je quitte c'est à dire je lui ai
écrit une lettre en disant pourquoi
j'arrêtais puisqu'il avait pris contact
avec nick ou pour essayer de mettre
ensemble tous les gens colère c'est à
dire les motards en colère les
fiscalistes et anti fiscaliste qui
regardent la télé pas tous ceux qui sont
en colère tous les groupes pour essayer
d'être le candidat de ceux en colère et
là je me bats en disant c'est pas du
tout comme ça qu'on a démarré
tu es en train de faire fausse route et
tout y continuent dans leur erreur ils
continuent à jouer la lutte il en disant
on nous empêche de parler il ya un
complot contre nous les flics nous
menace et il en arrive au point de faire
une deuxième conférence de presse celle
où il a la plume dans le cul en disant
je démarre à partir de maintenant vice
forme empêche de parler je démarre une
grève de la faim
essart sauf que ce qui m'a pas du tout
plu c'est que c'est une fausse grève de
la faim et il va faire un malaise le 1er
avril et au à personne ne s'aperçoit que
c'est le 1er avril quand même bien fait
semblant d'accord mais par rapport à ce
qui se passe politiquement je le prends
très très mal il ne sait et là il
m'écrit lettre en réponse à ma lettre
qui me fait envoyé par un coursier et
que je garde par devers moi ce champ
qu'il est encore blessé que le temps est
pas il va falloir qu'on mette un an
avant de se revoir et se retrouver de
discuter de tout ça donc la lettre
commence par doré elle m'est adressée
elle écrite à 2-2 sa main j'arrête je ne
suis plus candidat
d'abord parce que probablement je
n'aurais pas non plus les 500 signatures
grand baratineur en avait aucune pompe
vu que depuis qu'ils m'ont écrit pour me
promettre déjà beaucoup de maires m'ont
signifié qu'il ne pourrait pas confirmé
ou que leurs partis respectifs leur
avait interdit déjà la droite faisait le
barrage la gauche l'a fait aussi donc
blocage complet
j'avais proposé aux petits candidats
demeure de me rejoindre pour qu'ensemble
nous soyons fait là c'est le début et
fait alors il dit aussi je suis
interdite à la radio à la télé tous ceux
qui ont essayé de me soutenir se sont
fait virer la grande presse fait le
silence
mr se dégonfle tout part en couille moi
aussi j'ai voulu ça sert il c'est à tous
parents et moi aussi
la baisse est surtout c'est ça ses sept
frères à saissac un parent couilles il
avait voulu m'amuser quoi y amuser les
autres dans une période d'une grande
tristesse et d'un grand sérieux
c'est le sérieux qu'ils gagnent et bien
tant pis des gens seront déçus
je le suis aussi dans sa lettre coolus
s'adresse à la jeunesse ni j'espère
qu'un jour les jeunes pourront se
promener dans les rues sans que la
police ne les agresse aux retraités
j'espère qu'un jour les vieux auront une
retraite décente et qu'ils pourront
s'arrêter de travailler à un âge où on
ne peut encore profiter de la vie au
journaliste j'espère qu'un jour les
journalistes pourront exercer leur
métier sans être obligé de cirer les
pompes du pouvoir et sur la peur que
satan d'une candidature a généré 10
aujourd'hui je me demande comment j'ai
pu croire que ma candidature ferait rire
les médias et les hommes politiques
si j'avais fait 2 % dans les sondages on
aurait trouvé ça rigolo mais 10% c'est
trop et la conclusion de sa lette ces
messieurs les hommes politiques de
métier j'avais mis le nez dans le trou
de votre cul je ne vois pas l'intérêt de
le laisser
amusez vous bien mais sans moi coluche
voilà incroyable voilà qu on vous lit ce
soir dont touche pas à mon poste romain
goupil je voudrais vous remercie
et devrait vous remercier de nous avoir
révélé ce document exclusif merci
beaucoup et j'espère qu'on verra
merci beaucoup merci